- All right, bend over.
I'm going to wipe your butt.
(upbeat music)
- Put the goldfish back in the bowl.
- Don't eat the playdough.
- Where did this cup of dirt come from?
- Band-aids are not stickers.
- The oven is not a playhouse
for your stuffed toys.
- Don't eat candles.
- Get your hands out of the toilet.
- You don't have to watch me poop.
- Oh, why are there Legos
in the peanut butter?
- Come on, less singing, more pooping.
- Stop licking the dog.
- Spit that out in my hand right now.
- I know you gotta go, just hold it, okay?
You went?
No!
All right, dammit.
We got to get some towels.
- Stop kissing the dog on the mouth.
- Those gummy bears aren't
gonna fit up your nose.
- Take the headphones off the dog.
- We do not eat cookies out of the trash.
- The next time you want
to say hi to the neighbors
you have to put pants on.
- We do not eat grapes
we find in the car seat.
Give me the grape.
Give it.
I swear boy.
I will drive you to a
supermarket and leave you there.